foreign
[Music]
together
foreign
thank you
[Music]
the present of Ukraine his Excellency
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
we are here today on this historic
occasion to welcome the president of
Ukraine volodimir jelensky to the
European Parliament
this is an extraordinary moment in
extraordinary times
it has been almost one year since the
brutal illegal invasion of sovereign
Ukraine by Russia
in all that time Mr President your
leadership has inspired your people and
inspired every corner of the globe
when the world thinks of Ukraine they
think of the heroes fighting the odds
of David beating Goliath
they think of the icons of snake island
the Warriors of marupol the liberators
of so many occupied towns and villages
their names will be spoken of for
Generations
notwithstanding the bombs that fall
every day your grain continues to feed
the world
when a devastating earthquake hit turkey
and Syria you stood up and sent Rescuers
equipment and expertise that is real
solidarity
[Applause]
I am I am proud to say that this house
of European democracy its members our
European Union has always stood with you
we understand that you are fighting not
only for your values but for ours for
those ideals that bind us as sisters and
brothers
they make us all European because
Ukraine is Europe and your nature
nation's future is in the European Union
[Applause]
we know the sacrifice that your people
have endured for Europe and we must
honor it not only with words but with
action with the political will to ensure
easier trade and with the fastest
possible accession process
with funds for your people with help in
reconstruction with training for your
troops with military equipment and
defense systems you need to win and now
states must consider quickly as a Next
Step providing long-range systems and
the Jets that you need to protect the
Liberty too many have taken for granted
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
our response must be proportional to the
threat and the threat is existential
I grew up hearing my grandparents
stories of my country's last three
fighter planes
when all seemed lost when they had no
ammunition no food and no hope all that
remained were the three barely
functioning planes that they called
faith hope and charity named after what
they were fighting for after what was at
stake the plains meant one more day of
Liberty just long enough for help to
arrive they meant peace you do not need
to convince anyone here of how essential
it is to support Ukraine to back all
those giving their lives to support the
values we preach with concrete measures
to ensure Victory real peace based on
your ten point plan accountability for
those who committed war crimes and for
the protection of freedom for all
ukrainians
[Applause]
and I want to repeat the promise that I
made to you when we met in Kiev last
April we have your back we were with you
then we are with you now we will be with
you for as long as it takes Freedom will
prevail peace will reign you will win
slavo crying
[Applause]
thank you
glory to Ukraine
dear
Mrs president
[Applause]
Rebecca
I thank you
for these powerful words
and I thank you for your personal
attention
very important intention to Ukraine
thank you
for your and your principled and
energetic approach to qualities that we
see
unchanged during this struggle for
Europe
and the combination of those is a
precondition of for progress
Europe is lucky
that in this plenary hole in the biggest
parliament of Europe
in the European Parliament
principled approach and energized
approach
have an absolute majority enjoy an
absolute majority of thank you
thank you
representatives of Europe dear leaders
of Europe all of us Europeans
each and every hundreds of millions of
people in our continent
combine
these two statuses representatives of
Europe and leaders of Europe this
combination reflects
what our Europe
modern Europe
peaceful Europe gives to the world
European way of life
European
life standard European rules of life
when each and everyone
have matter when the law rules
the
rule of law when States strive to be
social and societies strive to be open
when a diversity is a value
and the values of different people are
united by
Fair quality
when borders are
not violated
and but when you don't feel that you
cross-borders when people Trust
and have faith in tomorrow and they're
ready to go to squares to fight for
their tomorrow when
between protesters and the president
president there's only one barrier and
that is honest elections
this is our Europe
these are our rules
this is our way of life
and for Ukraine
it's a way home
a way to its home
now I am here in order to defend
uh people's way home of all ukrainians
of all ages or and various political
convictions are various social status of
various religious conviction
convictions and
different histories but all of us enjoy
this common European history
the Ukrainian European way of life they
tried to annihilate it with through
Total War
after that why because after the
European Ukrainian European way of life
they want to destroy the European
way as such I've
out of all 27 elements of the European
way of life of 27 countries of the
European Union
we will not allow that
this Total War now
that was waged by Russia
is not only for the territory
for a territory in this or that part of
Europe the threat of it
is that there is a dictator with
massive supplies and reserves of Soviet
weapons and
weapons from dictatory regimes Iran in
particular in order to be able to fight
like this the Kremlin cynically and
deliberately year after year step after
step was trying to eliminate and destroy
what we see as our value in Europe the
value of human lives has been destroyed
in Russia for the authorities there
nobody is of value apart from those who
are in the Kremlin and have their own
wallets as
at heart 140 million of Russian citizens
for the leaders of Russia are just
bodies uh that are capable of carrying
weapons to Russia
the weapons that would be on the
battlefield and to keep everybody in
obedience so they could become the
supremacy of violence and obedience
these are the rules
instead of
look there
the Russian regime
not only hates
any social
Justice and diversity they invest in
xenophobia and try are trying to make it
part of normality on our continent and
trying to
make
the inhumane relatives of the 30s and
the 40s the 20th century a relative
today but this is the answer to that for
us is no no Europe we are defending the
we're descending from the anti-european
most anti-european force of the modern
world we are defending ourselves we
ukrainians on the battlefield together
with you
foreign
that we're defending it together and we
must defend ourselves and it's important
not only for these states of Europe not
only for the communities and Societies
in Europe no matter who we are and what
we are we always fight against
disrespect
and neglect wherever we live we're
always
put our
faith in Integrity forever for whatever
we dream for our children and
grandchildren
and the precondition for these dreams is
peace and security
and that is going to be
and whether it's going to be possible
if we do not overcome
the anti-european force that is trying
to steal from all of us
our Europe no only our victory
will guarantee all that
each of our European values
our
our victory that is going to be
that should be should happen that would
be mandatory dear leaders of Europe dear
president ladies and gentlemen dear
members of European Parliament dear
workers of the European Parliament here
and are the European institutions here
dear journalists
dear
Security Service workers their military
and army Personnel policeman rescue
workers dear workers and municipalities
diplomats
teachers professors scientists
are dear doctors drivers dear workers of
supports Farmers the industrious dear
workers at the industrial Enterprise
dear business owners small big
businesses dear workers said Banks dear
energy workers and electricity greater
workers dear Trade union workers dear
students and representatives of ngos
dear producers and actors lawyers
defense lawyers human rights Defenders
the destiny of Europe the fate of Europe
has never depended on politicians and
that should not be the Illusions now
each and every one of us matter
each and every one of you are strong
each and every one of you is capable to
impact and influence our common result
our common victory
and
and these Applause
are not directed to me Anatomy this
these Applause is actually for these
Applause I'd like to thank all of you in
Europe in hundreds of towns and Villages
who supported Ukraine
in this historic battle thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
I would like to thank you
to all of you who has been helping our
people our ordinary citizens our
resettled people here who called on
their leaders to increase and enhance
their support to protect our Ordinary
People those who were
on the squares who were raising
questions who was spreading truth about
the Russian aggression who was not
tempted by to consume Russian the
Russian disinformation and who's
standing by us in our fight for life for
Europe I thank you
I think all of us who help all of you
who helps Ukraine with vitally important
supplies weapons and ammunition and
energy equipment and fuel
thousands of things and items that would
be that we wouldn't be able to endure in
this total well I thank you ladies and
gentlemen and members of European
Parliament and to you personally Roberta
that you with your decisions
defend the European way of life without
a steadfastly that you defend the
Ukrainian European way of life
you approve courageous decisions
and you strengthen the European ambition
to be
a home for justice
and freedom and I recall the first day
of large-scale invasion when the Russian
ambition to Breakers and the entire
Europe was still
adamant and it was still
still one day the Russian
aggression was beginning to break their
tooth against fighting our defense on
this sixth day of the large-scale
invasion European Parliament approved
the resolution not simply to support our
state but to uh
approve the status of the candidate for
the European membership for our country
that was the vision that motivates
motivated us to be uh strong and to be
to stay uh to stay the course
thank you
today
during the meeting of the Council of
European Council I would be able to
thank personally the heads of state and
the governments for the decisions that
over the course of last year allowed our
continents to do what the previous wave
of leaders considered impossible Europe
at last is relieving itself of the
ruinous dependence on the Russian fossil
fuels Europe is cleansing itself of the
corruption influence of the Russian
oligarchy business Europe is defending
itself
from the infiltration of the Agents of
Russians secret Services who were
looking at Europe as the hunting field
for the opposition opponents of the
Russian regime for the first time in its
history the European Union is providing
the military assessment of such large
scale at such scale and for I see such a
positive uh assessment of reforms and
the European in the European country
that is fighting defending itself and is
modernizing and reforming its
institutions at the same time we're
approaching the European Ukraine is
going to be a member of the European
Ukraine
as that is winning
is going to be the member of the
European Union the European Union that
is winning
dear friends
perhaps somebody some of you didn't feel
earlier the part the powerful
uh the power the power of the European
wavelife and now together Ukraine and
the European Union countries
have made our strength of this why is it
possible because we combined a princess
principled and energetic approach
we all are equal we're all equal in
representing uh Europe and integrity
we know that everybody is a leader of
Europe in there
lives in their specific lives we
we do not do we're not going back in
front of the enemy we are defending so
we're not losing time we're changing
ourselves and we are changing
thanks Europe will always be and remain
Europe as long as we're together as long
as we take care of our Europe as we take
care of the European way of life
I thank all of you
I invite all of you
to Ukraine
glory to all ukrainians
and who who fight and glory to Ukraine
[Applause]
thank you so much thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
yes